los embajadores franceses se reunieron
para escuchar a su presidente marco les
dijo que estaba en una batalla de largo
aliento para defender la libertad y los
valores de europa en un mundo sacudido
por una serie de crisis incluyendo la
guerra en ucrania enmanuel manjón
prometió un apoyo inquebrantable a kiev
manteniendo al mismo tiempo la puerta
abierta el diálogo con moscú
hay que prepararse para una guerra larga
y para ello hay que organizarse a nivel
nacional y europeo sobre todo en materia
de energía de alimentos y de otras
muchas cuestiones de alimentación y
cultura
sin embargo está claro que ante esta
larga guerra debemos trabajar para
evitar la escalada y prepararnos para la
paz in action que difícil es que ha dado
este parate macon rechazó las críticas
de algunos países especialmente en
europa del este respecto a su decisión
de seguir hablando con rusia dijo que el
trabajo de un diplomático es hablar con
todo el mundo
si la diplomacia fuera el arte de hablar
con la gente con la que estamos de
acuerdo no propondría lo que he
mencionado anteriormente porque
necesitaríamos muchos menos puestos y
muchos menos recursos pero tenemos que
asumirlo no debemos ceder a ninguna
forma de falsa moral que no salen
potentes
sin uso en 311 sus prioridades en
política exterior son el apoyo económico
y militar a ucrania reforzar la unidad
europea y defensa más asertiva de los
intereses franceses en términos más
generales en los asuntos mundiales se
compromete a reconstruir la asociación
de francia con el continente africano
también dijo que habrá un acuerdo
nuclear con irán en los próximos días y
que parís debe trabajar con china para
abordar los desafíos globales como la
emergencia climática
manjón advirtió de las consecuencias de
una tendencia global de mayor división
que sólo puede conducir a un mundo más
frágil y dijo que francia continuará con
su tradición de independencia en los
asuntos internacionales